decision tree organized a series rules
in the tree structure it is one of the
most a practical method for
nonparametric supervisor learning our
goal in this video is to demonstrate how
to create a decision tree that predict
the value of a target by lending
decision rules inferred from the
training data let's first have a look at
the some important terminology of
decision tree the root node is at the
beginning of a tree it represents the
entire population being analyzes
splitting is the process of dividing a
node into sub nodes when a sub note can
be splitted into further nodes then it
is called decision nodes leaf nodes are
the nodes of a tree that have no further
split a nodes when we remove sub nodes
of a decision node this process is
called pruning this is the opposite
process of splitting which is used to
prevent overfitting now let's
demonstrate the process of creating a
decision tree from data
first of all let's inspect the data set
in this example there are two classes
and two features sets and color for the
training data we can construct to some
decision rules from the features for
example here are two simple decision
rules the first is whether the says
greater or equal to two and the second
is whether the color is yellow or not in
real application there are usually a lot
of decision rules we can choose from so
we need to find a way to choose the best
decision rule to split the current node
starting from the root node we are going
to iterate through all the decision
rules and calculate the information gain
of the current displayed calculate the
information gain is a centerpiece of
this step so what is information gain
let's have a closer look at each group
within the decision rule the group is a
pure when all of its records belong to
the same class here we use Gini impurity
to measure how pure the current node
AIDS when the group is pure guinea
impurity is zero when the group is
half-and-half mixed guinea impurities
0.54 any decision split a parent group
is split into two child groups the
information gain of this plate is the
impurity of the parent group manners
weighted average impurity of the child
group once we calculate the information
gain of h splitting decision rule we now
can select the decision rule which has
the largest information gain to split
the current node then we can split the
child node recursively and only
considering decision rule never selected
before in the current branch we stopped
splitting if there are no decision rules
left of the group impurity is zero
sometimes pruning and early stop
condition are used to prevent a large
number of splits and overfitting now the
decision tree can predict the
probability of each class at the ratio
of each class in the note in this case
for the record we says greater or equal
to two and color is yellow there is a
50% chance the class record it's a
circle so that is a brief demonstration
of how to construct the decision tree
from data it has a lot of advantages
like easy to interpret and
straightforward for visualizations
however it has a big disadvantage single
decision tree model are prone to
overfitting
especially when a tree is particularly
steep one way to combat this issue is by
setting a max depth of the tree this
will limit the risk of overfitting but
this will be at expense of increasing
bias
random forest is a good way to prevent
overfitting with Auto sacrificing buyers
it is simply a collection of decision
trees whose results are aggregated into
one final result it is a strong in
sample modeling technique at much more
robust than a single decision tree so in
real-world application people usually go
directly into using random forests for
modeling I hope you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to us and rain
the notification bell and stay tuned